joe concha joe
this reuters slash
other washington post other news outlet
situation is egregious like ashley said
it is horrible reuters article leaking
names states more data on canadian
freedom convoy donors leaked and then
ddos said that because donor information
contained sensitive personal information
it would not be making that data
available publicly but would instead be
offering it to journalists and
researchers how ridiculous and offensive
is this action by these so-called
journalists
i think that north korean state media
looks at this and says hey this is even
going too far for us right to dox people
who are simply trying to help those out
who are protesting uh i'm old enough to
remember the summer of 2020 when the
future vice president of the the united
states and kamala harris actually
started a bail fund uh for those in
minneapolis uh those who were riding at
the time and i don't remember anybody
being doxxed at that point as far as who
else uh may have been donating at that
time to that particular cause uh look
when you call truckers white
supremacists or nazis or and the fact
that the american people is squarely on
the side of the canadian government uh
when when a problem here clearly
that debate we just saw in parliament
that was a factual argument being made
you could agree or disagree with it as
far as that one member but then to
resort right to well you're only siding
with nazis at this point it reminds me
of the president united states who said
if you don't support voting rights you
therefore are on the side of jefferson
davis and bull connor look no one talks
about the science and data around covet
here cases in canada are down 90 when
compared to a month ago all right it's
down to about 5 000 cases a day in a
country of 37 million people so why
again is a vaccine mandate needed here
given transmission is dropping
precipitously for a profession where the
worker's almost always isolated from the
public the answer is this is about power
and nothing to do with science it's
about political science yeah and you
know you mentioned that justin trudeau
is calling the
people who support those truckers you
know people who wave swastikas he was
making that comment to
a lawmaker who's jewish and whose family
was actually suffered during the
holocaust
and and then also you think back
when it comes to this reuters reporting
you think back to what happened with the
hunter biden situation and how twitter
went to great lengths to censor that
reporting because of hacked information
are you seeing the same treatment of
this reporting that has recently been
released
boy it's it's a disturbing pattern uh
carly no question uh remember that with
hunter biden it wasn't
just that the american media in october
2020 so we're talking just a couple of
weeks before a presidential election
that they didn't report uh the contents
of his laptop that the new york post
originally broke
literally if you shared the story on
twitter your account got locked just ask
kelly mcinanny that happened to her when
she tried to share that story at the
time when she was white house press
secretary so it's not even just about
the bias of omission this is pure
outright censorship i bought up north
korea before and that's usually like the
hyperbole to end hyperboles as far as
government control is concerned but now
we're seeing it and we're supposed to be
democracies here in america and then
canada more socialist but still i would
think there would be a free press but no
we're going in that direction and too
many people in this industry are silent
about what's happening here and joe this
ilhan omar tweet condemning the doxing
of these donors is astounding because
you had ted cruz and others on the
conservative side saying listen to ilhon
here's what she says i fail to see why
any journalist felt the need to report
on a shop owner making such an
insignificant donation if she is calling
this out what does this say about the
state of journalism right now
wow i mean
when you have you know ted cruz and elon
omar republicans and democrats coming
together and saying that this is wrong
boy uh the state of journalism we've
talked about trust in media being at an
all-time low we're well past bias at
this point by the way it's journalists
becoming activists and taking aside and
actually trying to
steer an outcome and i don't know what
to say it's chilling there's no other
word to describe it hey joe leave with a
joke we're both seinfeld fans i do not
think there's been this much discussion
of canadian parliament since cramer said
he was going to go watch canadian
parliament you know what i'm talking
about love a seinfeld reference at 5 30.
so that was impressive yeah i know joe
koncha happy uh belated birthday to you
my friend
oh thank you so much it's never opposite
day with us guys we give the facts
that's the bottom line without a doubt
bye carly i went to brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now